das ist ein spektakuläres
forschungsergebnis das schwarze loch im
zentrum unserer milchstraße ist
explodiert und das ist nahezu
unvorstellbar die eruption stieß mehr
als 100 millionen mal mehr energie aus
als heute und das kann immer wieder
passieren klicks und fans im future hier
gibt es drei mal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
unser podcast dem begeistert mich jeden
tag mehr und zwar nicht nur weil die
idee ihn mit zusätzlichen infos neu
aufzunehmen nicht ganz übel war sondern
weil ihr ihn inzwischen in allen charts
nach oben steigen last also jetzt schon
mal der hinweis hier unter mir ist der
link anklicken anhören und abonnieren
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts und jetzt
noch an disclaimer weil ich manchmal bei
solchen meldungen nachrichten von
verängstigten leuten bekomme solche
ereignisse passieren in kosmischen
maßstäben sprich es geschah vor
jahrmillionen jahren und dass es wieder
passiert ist auch eine sache von
millionen jahren
also rein theoretisch könnte es
natürlich auch morgen passieren aber
dann kann man auch lotto spielen und
erwarten dass man immer gewinnt also bei
kosmischen katastrophen meldungen
einfach mal chillen entspannt
zurücklehnen und zwar so entspannt dass
man den podcast nochmals beim
einschlafen mit zusatzinfos hören kann
mal mehr mal weniger also auch wenn das
hier eine katastrophenmeldung ist wenn
es wieder passiert haben wir uns
menschen entweder selbst vernichtet oder
sind so etwas andere mutiert vor zwei
millionen jahren geschah im zentrum
unserer milchstraße eine katastrophe
kosmischen ausmaßes wobei man auch
gesagt muss für den kosmos für das
universum ist das völlig normal es gibt
ja quasi die noch mal deutlich aktiver
und heller sind vielleicht ist in
solchen galaxien mit einem so aktiven
schwarzen noch gar kein leben möglich
1960 hatten forschungsteams rätselhafte
radio quellen am himmel aufgespürt die
genau wie sterne radiowellen ins all
schicken
doch es konnte sich nicht um sterne
handeln denn dafür waren sie viel zu
weit weg das was die signale aussandte
war also entweder extrem nicht schwach
oder aber unsichtbar 1962 hatte man dann
bessere instrumente am start und den
forschungsteams gelang es doch etwas zu
erkennen also
doch etwas schwach leuchtende sterne
jedenfalls unvorstellbar weit weg von
uns das licht hatte mehrere milliarden
jahre zu unserer erde gebracht und so
konnte es sich eben eigentlich nicht um
einen stern handeln denn diesen hätte
man aus solch einer entfernung gar nicht
sehen können ein riesiges rätsel für
astronomen astronomen weltweit fest
stand zumindest schon mal ihren namen
getauft hatte man die kosmischen
objekten quasi abgeleitet von quasi
stella also kein stern aber irgendwie
doch
es nahm noch einige zeit in anspruch bis
bessere teleskope entwickelt worden
waren
die dann endlich die auflösung des
rätsels mit sich brachten quasare sind
die kerne von galaxien supermassereiche
schwarze löcher die besonders viel radio
strahlung aussenden die galaxie strahlt
am himmel also so hell wie ein stern ist
es aber nicht das klingt jetzt ein
bisschen paradox ein helles schwarzes
loch es strahlt nicht selbst sondern die
materie die in dieses schwarze loch
stürzt kreis vorher wie im wasser in
einem strudel um das schwarze loch bevor
es in das schwarze loch fällt dabei
entsteht eine extrem starke reibung und
die gase sternen und planeten brocken
heizen sich auf und leuchten erst ganze
36 jahre nach der entdeckung konnte eine
würz galaxie der quasare fotografiert
werden das gelang den weltraum teleskop
hubble und machte somit noch einmal
deutlich dass es sich bei den kosmischen
objekten um die hellen kerne von
galaxien handelt theoretischen
physikerinnen und physiker erkannten
schnell dass die unfassbare leuchtkraft
der quasare nicht mit der
thermonuklearen fusion wie sie im
sternen inneren abläuft zu erklären ist
sondern eben mit dem material strudel um
das schwarze loch der akkretionsscheibe
doch trotz intensiver forschung stellen
quasare die fachwelt weiterhin vor
spannende rätsel denn den gängigen
theorien zufolge entstehen
supermassereiche schwarze löcher dadurch
dass sie mit der zeit immer mehr gas und
umliegende sterne verschlingen bei der
supernova es loso massereicher sterne
könnte in dem nach deren vorläufer
entstehen möglicherweise sind auch die
verschmelzung solcher vorläufer wichtig
für das wachstum supermassereiche
schwarze löcher
eine sache ist jedenfalls klar alle
diese prozesse brauchen zeit und immer
mehr entdeckte schwarze löcher hatten
diese zeit nicht
ein anderer mechanismus muss sie
entstehen lassen haben den manche der
äußerst massereichen schwarzen löcher im
inneren von quasaren stammen aus der
frühesten anfangszeit des kosmos manche
sind sogar mehr als 13 milliarden jahre
alt dabei müssten sie doch nicht nur
viel zu wenig zeit sondern auch viel zu
wenig futter zur verfügung haben um zu
solchen extremen größe heranzuwachsen
denn fachleute sind sich sicher dass
sich sterne erst rund 100 millionen
jahre nach dem urknall entwickelt haben
die schwarzen löcher die wiederum aus
ihnen entstanden sein sollen muss man
jetzt sagen waren wohl viel zu klein um
sich direkt zu einem quadrat zu
entwickeln also für das universum ist
das geschehen hier in unserer
milchstraße eher eine nebensache aber
für uns hier auf der erde muss es
spektakulär gewesen sein aber auch nicht
tödlich denn aus dieser zeit ist kein
massenaussterben oder sonstiges bekannt
trotzdem es war gigantisch bundes zeigt
das schwarze loch im zentrum unserer
milchstraße sagittarius stern kann immer
wieder auf diese art und weise
explodieren denn heute ist es im zentrum
der milchstraße eher ruhig allerdings
gibt es riesige rest sind dieser
explosion zwei kammern blasen über und
unter dem schwarzen loch im zentrum
unserer milchstraße
bei der ersten entdeckung 2010 wusste
man nur das ist ein absolut gigantisches
ereignis war das erzeugt hat aber es
liegt verborgen was das ereignis
wirklich war und eine weitere spur
entdeckten forschende die die exklusion
belegt eine gaswolke die sich zwischen
unserer nachbargalaxien der großen und
der kleinen magellanschen wolke
erstreckt sie glüht die energien aber
der sterne die sich in den nachbar
galaxien befinden sie zu schwach um
diesen effekt zu erzielen
einzige erklärung deshalb eine gewaltige
eruption des schwarzen lochs im zentrum
unserer milchstraße sagittarius stern
seit 1996 ist uns ein seltsames leuchten
des makedonischen stroms aufgefallen
aber wir haben die ursache nicht
verstanden
in diesem jahr dämmerte es mir
schließlich dass das zeichen die fossile
aufzeichnung eines riesigen energie
ausbruchs aus dem supermassiven
schwarzen loch im zentrum unserer
galaxie sein muss so oft betroffen von
der university of sydney und weiter seit
20 jahren haben astronomen vermutet dass
ein signifikanter ausbruch stattgefunden
hat aber jetzt wissen wir wann dieser
schlafende 3
der die vier millionen fache masse der
sonne hat erwacht ist und feuer mit der
100 millionen fachen kraft gespuckt hat
die heute hat so der professor
100 millionen mal stärker als heute das
ist schon wahnsinn diese
forschungsarbeit ist übrigens aus dem
jahr 2013
trotzdem immer noch hammer ich fand sie
so spannend dass ich unbedingt davon
berichten wollte und sie zeigt mal
wieder auf welchen umwegen die
wissenschaft maria zu ihren
erkenntnissen kommen schreibt mal bitte
in die kommentare ob ich mehr über
solche arbeiten berichten soll die top
spektakulär aber eben nicht topaktuell
sind allerdings sind die gamma blasen ja
gerade erst visualisiert worden und bis
dato war gar nicht so klar dass es zwei
waren und weil die zweite fehlte war
auch gar nicht so klar ob sie
tatsächlich von einem schwarzen loch im
zentrum unserer milchstraße stammt ein
neues bild des deutschen
weltraumteleskops rosita zeigt die
beiden kammern blasen eindeutig die
orange gelben insektenflügel die
nördliche struktur ist schon seit
längerer zeit bekannt weil aber die
zweite blase nicht auffindbar war galt
sie in fachkreisen auch als die glut
einer sternenexplosion die aufnahme von
rosita zeigt jetzt aber dass es sich
eben um die spuren einer mega explosion
des zentralen schwarzen lochs
sagittarius stern handelt und das ist
die explosion über die ich gerade
berichtet habe das legt die existenz
eben der zweiten blase im süden nahe
mehr dazu gibt es in diesem video
verschwundene materie gefunden durch
deutsches weltraum teleskop also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
denn das weltraumteleskop entdeckte auch
die verschwundene materie hammer thema
hammer video und ihr seid auch hammer
aber nur wenn der computer abonniert
also bis dann bleibt dran